[Music]
thank you and hi everyone I'm Lynne
Clark and I make code cartoons and I
also work at Mozilla I'm in the emerging
technologies group there so that's
things like the Russ programming
language and servo which is a new super
fast rent a browser engine and web
assembly which is what I'm going to be
talking about today since this is Jas
called I'm guessing that most of you are
JavaScript developers and so you know
that in JavaScript circles today there's
a lot of hype about web assembly people
are talking about how blazingly fast it
is and how it's going to completely
change the way that we do web
development but a lot of these
conversations don't go into details
about exactly what it is about web
assembly that makes it fast and I know
when I hear this kind of rhetoric but I
don't hear the details to back it up the
inner skeptic and me comes out so in
this talk I don't just want to tell you
about how fast
what assembly is going to be but I want
to help you understand what it is about
web assembly that makes it fast and in
what circumstances is fast but first
what is web assembly web assembly is a
way to run programming languages other
than Java Script in your webpages so in
the past when you wanted to run code on
a web page you had to use JavaScript if
you wanted to change the DOM and
response to an event or run a
calculation you were using javascript
but with web assembly it will be
possible to do these things with other
languages besides JavaScript so when
people say that web assembly is fast
well they're comparing it to is
JavaScript that's the apples to apples
comparison now I don't want to imply
that it's an either-or decision that
you're either going to be using web
assembly or you're going to be using
javascript
in fact we think that people are
probably going to be using these two
hand-in-hand and their applications but
it is useful to compare the two so that
you understand what this improved
performance of code running on the web
could mean in order to understand this
let's look at a little bit of
performance history of code running on
the web javascript was created in 1995
and it wasn't designed to be fast there
are a number of features and JavaScript
that make it hard to make it fast and
you heard a little bit about that this
morning there are things like dynamic
types where you have a variable that
could be a string or an integer and you
don't know even at runtime that variable
could change but these features also
make it easy for developers to get up
and running with JavaScript really
quickly so JavaScript developers
accepted this trade-off they accepted
that their code code was going to run a
little bit slower because of this ease
of use and for the first decade of
JavaScript that was true that JavaScript
was pretty slow and then the browser's
started getting more competitive in
about 2008 a period started called the
performance Wars where the browser
vendors started improving their jeaious
engines to make things much faster and
the techniques that they used with
introducing JIT compilers to the
JavaScript engine and I'll explain a
little bit more about that later but for
now let's look at the impact that these
JIT compilers had with the introduction
of the jig's you see an inflection point
in the performance of JavaScript all of
a sudden javascript code was only about
10 times faster than i had previously
and these performance improvements
continued over the next decade with this
improved performance you start seeing
javascript being used for things that
you never would have expected so things
like node an electron and these new
applications are possible because of
this improvement in performance it's
because of this inflection point ten
years ago that we have the applications
that we do today that's why it's
interesting that we may be approaching
another one of these inflection points
in
speed of code running on the web with
web assembly and this is where I need to
start backing up what I'm saying with
some details to do this I need to
explain a little bit about where
JavaScript spends its time today here's
a diagram of where the j/s engine spends
this time for a hypothetical app now
this isn't showing an average for any
particular app is going to be quite
different but we can use this to build
up a mental model and you may have seen
diagrams like this one before and be
confused why there are fewer categories
in this one I've condensed the number of
categories just so it's easier to reason
and talk about it so these categories
are parsing compiling and optimizing
reoptimize acute encoder '[ __ ]
collection now let's look at what this
diagram would look like for web assembly
you'll notice that some of the bars are
shorter and some are missing and in this
talk I want to explain what web assembly
changes how it makes the amount of time
that the engine spends in these tasks
shorter or get rid of them altogether
but first let's look at where j/s
engines would be if we hadn't introduced
the JIT in the early days of JavaScript
this diagram would have looked more like
this there was parsing running the code
and garbage collection what made the
execution more shorter what made that
run faster was the introduction of the
JIT and this little bit of overhead that
it added the compiling and optimizing
now with web assembly we want to make
these bars even shorter and in order to
see how we can do that we're going to
need to need to dive into the work that
the JIT does so I'm going to go through
a quick crash course in just-in-time
compilers and this is a general overview
the different engines have different
architectures and those architectures
have changed over time but most of this
applies to most of them right now this
may be review for some of you but will
be quick I just want to make sure that
we're all up to speed on this when
you're developing you have a goal and a
problem your goal is that you want to
tell the computer what to do
the problem is that you speak a human
language and the machine speaks a
machine language even if you don't think
of JavaScript as a human language it
really is because it's been designed for
human cognition not for machine
cognition I think of this like the movie
arrival we have aliens and humans trying
to communicate with one another it's not
as easy as translating word-for-word
from one language together because the
two groups actually have different ways
of seeing the world and that's true of
humans and machines too I'll explain
more about the differences in the way we
think later but let's look at the
process of translating in programming
there are generally two ways of
translating you can either use an
interpreter or a compiler when an
interpreter the translation happens
pretty much on the fly line by line a
compiler on the other hand doesn't
translate on the fly it takes time ahead
of time to create that translation and
then hand it off there are pros and cons
to each way each of these ways of
handling this translation so for an
interpreter some of the pros are that's
quick to get up and running you get that
immediate feedback loop so an
interpreter seems like a natural fit for
something like JavaScript where you want
the developer to see their progress
really quickly and that's why in the
beginning browsers use javascript
interpreters but the trade-off is that
when you're doing something like a loop
where you have to run the same code over
and over again you're doing that
translation over and over again the
compiler has opposite trade-offs it
takes a little bit more time to start up
because it has to go through that
compilation step ahead of time but then
you don't incur that translation cost in
loops where you're running the code over
and over again and another difference is
that interpreters are running during the
execution of the code so they can't take
too much time to actually think about
how the machine thinks and what the
optimal way to communicate with the
machine is what the instance compilers
are working ahead of time they can take
that little bit of extra time and think
about how to best communicate
with the machine and you'll hear that
referred to as optimization to get the
best of both worlds
browsers started mixing compilers in
they added a new part of the JavaScript
engine called a monitor or a profiler
the monitor watches the code as it runs
and it keeps track of things like how
often a function is being executed at
first the monitor just runs everything
through the interpreter and if the same
function has run a few times that
function is called warm as a function
warms up it gets sent off to the
baseline compiler to create a compiled
version of it so the baseline compiler
is going to start making this compiled
version but it's going to do it in
chunks each operation in the function is
going to be compiled to one or more
stubs so for example the plus equals
sign would be in operation the compiler
would create a stub for that and the
stuff will be specific to whatever types
were being used on the other either side
of that operator so if the sum and the
array element here were integers it
would compile to integer addition it's a
monitor hit set operation again with the
same variable type so with integers
again then it just pulls out the stuff
it has and uses that and if it has
different runs into this operation with
different variable types it will create
another stub and store that one as well
as the code runs more baseline steps for
more operations will be filled in and
this will save on translation time and
help speed things up but like I
mentioned there's more that a compiler
can do it can take some time thinking
about how the machine thinks and how to
best communicate with the machine it can
take time to make those optimizations
now the baseline compiler will make some
optimizations but it doesn't want to
take up too much time because the code
is executing at the same time but if the
code is really hot if it's being run a
whole bunch then it can be worthwhile to
actually go through and take the time to
make that optimization so when a part of
the code is very hot the monitor will
send it to the optimizing compiler and
this will create another even faster
version of that function
in order to make the faster version of
the function the optimizing compiler has
to make some assumption for example if
it can assume that all of the objects
that are created by a particular
constructor have the same shape so that
is the object has the same property
names and they've been added in the same
order then it can cut some corners based
on that
so the optimising compiler uses the
information that the monitor has been
gathering to make these judgments and if
something has been true for all previous
passes through the code then it assumes
it's going to continue to be true but of
course with JavaScript there are never
any guarantees you could have 99 objects
that all have the same shape but then
the hundreds object has a different
property or a property's been deleted on
it so the compiled code needs to check
before it runs to see whether the
assumptions are valid and if they are
then the compiled code runs but if not
the JIT assumes that it made the wrong
assumptions and trashes the optimized
code at this point the execution goes
back to the interpreter or to the
baseline compiled version and this
process is called the optimization or
bailing out usually optimizing compilers
will save you time they will actually
make the code run faster but if you have
code that keeps hitting you know gets
optimized and then gets bailed out on
and then gets optimized again if you get
in C cycles it can actually take more
time than it would have just running
through the baseline compiled version of
the code so a lot of jets will keep
track of how many times they've tried to
optimize a function and if it just keeps
not working out then they'll mark it as
don't even try optimizing this again so
that is the JIT in the nutshell
code starts off running in an
interpreter and the monitor collects
information about it and then it will
send code off to be compiled depending
on how often that part of the code is
being run now that we understand more
about the work that the JavaScript
engine is doing let's look at ways to
maybe make this execution go a little
faster
one way would be to get rid of some of
the overhead so we can move some of this
ahead of time but in order to do that we
would need to get rid of the dynamic
type if we're going to be optimizing
ahead of time we need the types to be
explicit in the code because we aren't
going to be monitoring it at runtime and
seeing what types are flowing through it
so these dynamic types that can change
at runtime are a problem but I already
suggested that that was part of what
made JavaScript successful the dynamic
types help developers get up and running
quickly why would we want to change
something that made JavaScript
successful I want to be clear here that
we don't have to change anything in
JavaScript to take advantage of the
benefits of web assembly but there is a
change that's already happening which we
can take advantage of and that is the
move towards modularity over the past
few years both with NPM and with the
es2015 modules back JavaScript has
become a much more modular eyes
ecosystem and the nice thing about
modules is that they provide boundaries
you don't really need to know about the
inner details of a module that you're
depending on so these modules they could
be compiled ahead of time using a
language that doesn't have these
flexible types that JavaScript does and
it wouldn't affect how you code take for
example react which has a lot of
different consumers the react core team
has already been working on making their
reconciliation algorithm faster an
option for them would be to rewrite that
req Rick the new reconciliation
algorithm in a language that has typed
something like C and then compile it
ahead of time but as long as they keep
the API the same consumers of react
actually wouldn't notice this when they
update the code the only thing they
would notice is any performance
improvements so this is what webassembly
does it makes it possible for library
authors and application developers to
code in languages that are more
consistently performant but then tab
that code run on the web just like
JavaScript does and to integrate with
existing JavaScript this means that
you'll be able to benefit from
webassembly with
out having to understand it or why it's
fast but I always find it more rewarding
when I do understand that stuff so I'm
going to go ahead and walk you through
how web assembly works in order to do
that I'm going to have to go through
another little crash course this time in
assembly in compilers I talked about how
communicating with the machine is like
communicating with an alien I want to
take a look now at how that alien brain
works how the communication that's
coming into it gets parsed and
understood there's a part of this alien
brain that's dedicated to the thinking
like adding and subtracting and logic
and there's also a part of the brain
near that which is a short-term memory
and those parts are pretty close
together in the same part of the brain
and then there's some longer term memory
so this is these different parts have
different names so the part that sense
of thinking is the arithmetic and logic
unit the ALU the short-term memory those
are called registers and that's all
encapsulated in the central processing
unit of a CPU and then the longer term
memory that's random access memory or
Ram each little part of the short-term
memory has a name and this makes it
easier for the brain to understand what
it should be working on and in a given
time the sentences in machine
communication are called instructions
when one of these instructions comes
into the brain it gets split up into
parts that means different things so the
way that this instruction is going to be
split up is going to be very specific to
the wiring of this particular brain for
example this brain might always take the
force through the tenth bit and pipe
that into the ALU and then based on
where there are ones and zeros the ALU
will figure out what exact they supposed
to do for this instruction so then the
brain would take the next two chunks to
figure out what it needs to do that that
operation on and these would be the
addresses of registers you'll see that
I've been adding annotations above the
machine code here that makes it easier
for us humans to understand what's going
on with this machine code and
that's actually what assembly is it's
called symbolic machine code it's a way
of human beings being able to read and
understand machine code you can see here
that there is a one-to-one relationship
between the assembly and the machine
code for this machine something you
might have figured out from that is that
you actually have a different kind of
assembly for each kind of wiring you
have for a machine anytime that you have
a different architecture inside of a
machine anytime there's a different kind
of brain in the machine there's a good
chance that we'll have its own assembly
so we're not talking about the target of
this translation just being one thing
just being one kind of machine code it's
many different kinds of machine code
just as we speak different languages as
humans machines speak different
languages so we're talking human to
alien translation you may be going from
English or Russian or Mandarin to alien
language a or two alien language be in
programming terms this is like going
from C or C++ or rust to x86 or to arm
if you want to be able to go from any
one of these high level programming
languages down to any one of these
assembly languages you're going to need
to create a whole bunch of different
translators that would be pretty
inefficient so what most compilers do is
they put at least one layer between the
compiler we'll take the high-level
programming language and translate it
down to something that's not quite as
high-level but is not as low-level of
machine code and this is called an
intermediate representation so the
compiler will take any one of the higher
level programming languages and go down
to the single intermediate
representation and then go from the
single intermediate representation to
any one of the assembly languages the
thing that goes from the higher level
programming language to the intermediate
representation is called a front-end and
the thing that goes from the
intermediate representation down to the
assembly is called a back-end so now
where does web assembly fit in this
picture well you might think that is one
of these target assembly languages which
is kind of true
except that each one of those languages
corresponding to a particular
architecture and when you're delivering
code across the web you don't actually
know what architecture you're going to
be running on so web assembly is a
little bit different from normal
assembly it's a machine language for a
conceptual machine not an actual
physical machine once the browser
downloads the web assembly you can make
the short hop between the web assembly
code and the actual assembly code for
that particular architecture let's look
through the tools that a developer of a
library like react would use to make
their code web assembly the compiler
tool chain that's had a lot of work go
into it for web assembly is called LLVM
and there are a number of different
front-ends and backends for LLVM so if
we wanted to go from C to web assembly
we might use clang as our front-end and
now to take us down from C to the
intermediate representation and then
once the code is in the intermediate
representation LLVM can actually do some
optimizations on top of that for us
because it understands it at that point
and then we want to go from the
intermediate representation down to web
assembly there's a back-end that's
currently in progress for all ovm that
will go all the way to web assembly but
you might not want to use it until it's
fully finished and in that case there's
another tool called in scriptum which
does have a fully finished back-end web
assembly back-end I uses a fork of LLVM
under the hood even after the LLVM
back-end is done you still may want to
use them script in to compile your code
it can be used to pack in some
interesting and useful libraries things
like a file system that works on top of
indexeddb
but regardless of whether you're using
LLVM to get there or i'm scripting to
get there the end result is a file that
ends in dot wasm for web assembly this
is the web assembly module and it can be
loaded in JavaScript right now the way
that you load it in javascript is a
little bit complicated and we're working
on making that easier web pack has plans
to work on it and other module loaders
are also working on
Plus once the browsers have the built-in
module support webassembly can use that
too so it should be as easy as loading a
JavaScript module when I say that though
I should add a caveat loading a web
assembly module should be as easy as
loading a JavaScript one but working
with it is going to be a little bit
different let's say you're calling a web
assembly function from JavaScript and
this is the web this is the JavaScript
function and this is the web assembly
function functions in web assembly can
only take web assembly types as
parameters and at the moment that's
numbers so integers floats that's what
you're working with so that's different
from regular JavaScript modules and the
same restriction applies to return
values as well but what if you want to
be able to return a string you can't do
it for any data types that are more
complex you need to put them in the web
assembly modules memory so this memory
is an array buffer it's just a
JavaScript object that simulates a heap
the integers could get passed back and
forth can be used kind of like pointers
into this heap so the C code can use
that to write to the memory as if it
were an address and then the JavaScript
can use that number to figure out the
array index that it needs to pull the
value from it's likely that anybody
who's developing a web assembly module
for developers is going to create a
wrapper around it so that you don't
actually need to know about that but I
think it helps to understand the
performance Karos fix understanding how
the memory works what I want to do now
is go back to this diagram and look at
what it is about web simply that can
make things run faster so first off this
isn't actually shown in the diagram but
it can take less time to download web
assembly than it does JavaScript because
it's more compact it was designed
specifically to be compact and it can
also be translated into a binary form
even though Jesus JavaScript is pretty
small if you have the
swivelling code and webassembly it's
likely that will be smaller parsing
takes less time than javascript show
javascript needs to be parsed from the
source into an abstract syntax tree and
then it's usually converted into an
intermediate representation called
bytecode that's specific to the
JavaScript engine that's running that
code web assembly is already a bytecode
it just needs to be decoded from that
binary version and decoding is faster
than parsing compiling takes less time
because a lot of it has been done ahead
of time before the file is even put up
to the server plus the compiler doesn't
have to compile those multiple baseline
stubs that it was doing for for the
dynamic type and you don't get into the
optimize and C optimize cycles that you
did with the JIT running your code is
fast because many of the optimizations
that it makes the JIT makes to
JavaScript just aren't necessary with
web assembly plus whether simply itself
provides many instructions that are just
faster human programmers don't actually
need to program web assembly directly so
that means that its designers could
create something that's closer to how
machines think so depending on what kind
of code your your code is doing these
instructions can run anywhere from ten
percent to eight hundred percent faster
and as for garbage collection at least
for now
the languages that are supported use
manual memory management and this is
likely to change I'll explain more about
that later but for now you don't need to
worry about garbage collection so what
is the status of web assembly right now
in late february the browser vendors
announced that web assembly was ready to
ship all by default and browsers and we
started shipping an on by default in
firefox the next week and then chrome
did the same to week after that and it's
currently in preview versions of edge
and Safari with this developers can
start shipping web assembly code for
earlier versions of browsers that don't
support web assembly you can ship down
an atom jf' version as in chances the
precursor to web assembly but it's fully
JAF what the browsers is the MVP the
Minimum Viable Product
the MVP doesn't contain all of the
features of the community group once but
with it webassembly is reasonably fast
and usable however it should get even
faster in the future through a
combination of fixes and the engines and
new features in the spec for example a
fixed set needs happen in Firefox
specifically is that currently calling a
web assembly function and J's code is
slower than it needs to be and that's
because it has to be something called
trampolining so instead of the JIT
knowing how to deal directly with web
assembly code it has to go through a
setup function and that transfers the
control from JavaScript to web assembly
this is a lot slower than would be if
the JIT knew how to handle this function
itself now slower is relative we're only
talking nanoseconds here but if you have
lots of back-and-forth communication
between web assembly and JavaScript you
can notice that so that's the kind of
fix that you can expect in the engine as
for this back there are a number of
features that are coming soon one that's
expected reasonably soon is threading
one way to speed up the code is to make
it possible for different parts of the
code to run at the same time in parallel
but this can sometimes backfire since
the overhead of communication between
threads can take up more time than it
would owes to just run that all
sequentially but if you share memory
between the threads it reduces this
overhead to do this
what assembly will use the new shared
array buffer that's being shipped in
browsers shortly once that's in place
and browsers the community group can
start specifying how web assembly will
use it another feature that needs to be
standardized is direct Dom access
currently there's no way to interact
with the DOM and that means that you
can't do something like element set
element inner HTML to update the node
from web assembly instead you have to go
through jas to set that value the
community group is currently working on
adding Dom support though and one last
feature that has a lot of folks excited
is integration with the browser's
garbage collection so today you can
chips down your own garbage collector
with your code if you want to but that's
kind of slow for a few reasons
and it's also hard to integrate with the
browsers
built-in GC but the community group is
working on making it possible for web
assembly code to be used with just the
built in GC which is a highly optimized
one that the browser's have been working
on so it will run fast and you'll have
that integration unfortunately that's
all I have time to talk about today so I
have to wrap it up but before I do I
want to give a thank you
I had fantastic technical review on this
from Luc Wagner he is the person who
came up with the way to add add pipes
and azzam jf and he also did a lot of
the work to push web assembly forward
unfortunately he's here today so the two
of us will be beginning a QA about web
assembly in the Mozilla space at lunch
so come feel free to come and ask us
questions or you can ask on Twitter or
we'll both be at the party tonight so
thank you to him and thank you all for
listening
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]